please welcome the ace of cakes and my
children's personal hero jeff goldman
hey how's it going duff i'm so excited
to tell you that the other night i came
home with two cookbooks because this is
cookbook club and
i'm a big cookbook uh junkie and
so i brought out two cookbooks and i was
like okay so we're gonna make like a
savory meal
and then a dessert and the only thing
she wanted to do of course
was everything out of your book and
nothing to do with the cheeseburgers i
was trying to get us to make
now i'm so excited because i must say
when you're doing cake week and you get
to work with duff
i mean come on what are we making
today that we can all be the heroes to
our kids
so uh so this is a really fun recipe now
this is adapted from
a cookies and cream cupcake that's in
uh super good bacon for kids and the
recipe was actually
inspired by one of the kids on kids
baking championship
she made a cupcake and made a graham
cracker crust
and i've never seen a cupcake
with a cookie crust before and i was
like that's
genius so we took these peppermint
cookies they're like peppermint oreos
basically you can get them anywhere
you just add some butter and salt and
then you press it into
the cupcake liners and just kind of dump
it in there
right just press the cookies down so
they're nice and
nice and tightly packed and then
we're going to stick this in the oven
only for like five minutes or so
it's really fast okay uh you want to
bake these off
at 3 25. all right now um
take like your chocolate cake batter now
this is the one from the book it's got a
little bit of butter a little bit of oil
and buttermilk so now we're going to
fill the cupcakes
okay so get some chocolate batter i have
a little ice cream scoop
let me show you how to do this with
tablespoons
you know get your tablespoon and then
take the second one
and you just slide it in there so if you
don't have a fancy
cupcake measurer just use tablespoons
i don't oh there's the kitchen cat
there's a kitchen cap yeah arthur
i call him the kitchen cat because he
often coos and purrs
when yummy delicious things are taking
place
you know when uh when i first started
charm city cakes
i uh i couldn't afford like a place to
live so i i lived above the bakery i had
like a little apartment up there
really and i had a cat and her name was
margo
and uh it was weird because for some
reason
at five o'clock every day she would come
downstairs and we called her five
o'clock margot
because like it was like at five o'clock
it was like oh five o'clock margo and
she would come downstairs
say hi to everybody and then go back
upstairs all right so we're gonna bake
these off
uh for um i don't know 19
20 minutes or so at what temp saying 3
25.
got it i love
hearing that you were
economically challenged had to live in
the place above your bakery because you
become
such an empire and i think it's really
good for aspiring chefs
to hear that story because it's
incredible
what you've built your life into yeah
you know
owning a business is i personally i
think it's it's one of the most
wonderful
and terrifying things ever wow i have
like you know
30 employees and you know like all these
customers that are going to be getting
wedding cakes this weekend but
it's also one of the best feelings in
the world that like on friday
when you're looking at all the cakes you
made that week
and they're all there and everything is
ready to go for saturday
and you're like look at our body of work
this is great
yeah i bet you get some crazy ladies uh
on the precipice of their wedding by the
way
okay now def guide me through piping
should i start around the edges or in
the center and build out
yeah so start in the center and then
build out oh my god i've done this
before look at that it's perfect
it's literally perfect i
thanks guys thank you so much
and then
oh yeah i see what you're doing okay
we're going like
1980s wolfgang puck on this piece i see
really really chef 1980s i mean you
remember desserts in the 80s and what
they look like
my idea of like desserts in the 80s was
like mcdonald's apple pie
by the way and they've changed that
recipe and i
am peeved yeah cause they they think i
my first job was at mcdonald's we used
to deep fry the pies yeah
that's why they were so delicious now
they're baked
i couldn't agree more put that apple fry
in that hot oil it had like bubbles
in the dough it's wrong
[Music]
all right oh you want to have some fun
yeah
[Applause]
yes i feel like
i i feel like i i feel like you just
really got some frustration out
there true
and now you can sprinkle
yeah this looks so pretty
i'm so excited my kids are gonna freak
out what you can do
so if you want to take some of the
cookie crumbs that don't have any of the
butter
uh-huh uh-huh so you have cookie crumbs
on the sides uh-huh i love it this is
joyful
wait i'm getting word that there's a
surprise
is this true
oh my
[Applause]
oh surprises gosh there's newspapers
everywhere
this is the coolest thing i've ever seen
you got like a blouse that's just like
mine
and the backdrop oh my gosh i can't
believe this
thank you so much doc you are welcome
thanks for having me this is
really fun i wish you the best
go to the jupiter.com for the full
recipe of what duff and i just did
i'll be doing it with my kids tonight
[Music]